oh I forgot to join the tournaments ah
okay I guess I late joins so I'm not
gonna play oh I do play a strong player
okay yeah it is 5:00 a.m. on Sunday
playing the hourly rapid arena I don't
think I've played I've ever played a
tournament at this time but we'll see
how it goes
we have a Catalan variation durability -
I like to play c5 this is uh this is
known as array Robson variation Rae made
a popular when he was like 15 years old
so about ten years ago
yeah Queen a4 is very direct attempt to
win back the pond and yeah there's a few
ways like coming back upon it looks like
there's a lot of pressure there's
actually a trap in the sign if white
takes twice on c6 or three times on c6 I
should say Knight d7 Queen takes e4 all
I'll have rook seen CX oh it's gonna
happen it might happen er yeah rook c8
perfect CHS winds on the spot it's all
opening preparation hello to people
you're joining it a nice time why am I
not sleep because I'm awake I'm
conscious yeah
why I can resign now like there's really
no there's no great fights Wow thirteen
moves maybe that will go on YouTube
maybe this whole tournament will go on
YouTube I don't know if just this game
goes on YouTube YouTube people follow me
on Twitch
and thank you bicycle bicycle welcome
back AHA it's a bass but I think you
wrote bass
thanks for the sub for five months and
pawning boots for four months yeah hello
to so many people who is first ashrak
ashrak Tosh did congratulations
Easton second carbon chair I should be
asleep what am i doing that's a great
great sense to say at this time
yes I'm awake
I've been training myself to stay awake
later so that by the time the candidate
starts I'll be able to stay awake
through the round and work through the
round so yeah we'll see how long the
stream goes also yeah shout out to the
Europeans
I won't bezerk I'll try and keep it
chill I do want to win the tournaments
but it's still very early I'll play
tonight Oh what do I want to play here
let's play 9 f3
I'm playing at C 3 the Smoove order
avoids this fashion cough sometimes
confuses people d 6 ok so yeah I guess
I'll go for an open Sicilian and see
what black is up to hmm
Belgian novice how's it going something
for 22 months thanks so much
okay we're gonna have a dragon ooh I
don't really know how to play the
tracking is white I assume a three
I mean I've I've played the dragon is
black on stream before I want to play a
sideline here like we need you to what
time is it at my place
it's 504 a.m. yeah I don't want to mess
with a mainline I mean there's two like
main moves here between castling and
Bishop c4 pretty sure h4 is a move it's
like or just trying to like get out of
theory even though it's probably still
some kind of theory yeah we have we have
Jordan Melbourne Denmark India yeah
there's probably very few people from
from North America watching compared to
all the Europeans Australians
kuzuri how's it going to have infer okay
so h5 is very typical I mean yeah I'm
kind of just improvising this makes
sense at some point I want to do this
and this and tack trying to rely on just
intuition
I've seen many dragon games over the
years 6 e 6 is how full but also hurtful
for black so it undermines my bishop but
it's weakening to this in this
I'm not sure if I can punish it I mean
Bishop III looks I'm pretty typical
might be asking for 95 that's okay
this is a very typical like Dragon type
move from the white side because usually
Knight e5 or Knight a five comes with
tempo or even d5 comes with tempo and
Submission so better to keep it safe
stay flexible
if Belarus New Zealand Bangladesh oh
maybe maybe I'll do geoguessr I did
geoguessr my favorite stream and it's
nice my skiing with people watching from
all over the world
you are slow I'll take that as a
compliment
kind of I don't know I guess yeah and
I'm a bit slower in the morning what to
do a six tempted to take also like
castling queenside makes sense
while the moves to consider here like
take some Bishop h6 I think I'll just
castle it makes sense to have the the
rook queen battery against the D pawn
maybe right back left my what was making
that noise not sure Tom a 5-1 hi how's
it going thanks for subbing for four
months
ok so I can win a pawn I can take and
take here I was thinking of to try and
like just attack on the Kings side but a
pawn is a pawn Oh when am I gonna try
and go for a GM norm I was actually
supposed to play a tournament this month
in Vietnam where GM norms would have
been possible but they got cancelled so
I don't know when my next tournament
will be but it's not my my main priority
[Music]
we have we have more places Australia
Switzerland Syria Berlin nice to see
Queen b7 ok that's a good sign I think
I'll play play this move I mean this
looks like full domination like box
pieces are stuck
especially this bishop the bishop d7 I
take and take meanwhile I probably want
to play e5 94 g4 still kind of in the
air yeah our job off with drew he
withdrew it was it was just over a week
ago I feel like he withdrew a few days
before like the whole craze of klaris
but before things got like really crazy
in the media so yeah the candidates is
still set to take place a few days put
out a bunch of statements but as far as
I know all the players arrives oh we
have we have Lithuania Slovenia England
Poland Dresden
nice to see any anyone from America or
Canada
I need North Americans here if not
that's okay
I hope hope the people watching are
grateful that I'm streaming at this time
there should be seven or ki8 we can just
play e5 just shut down the bishop and
now f6 is a major hole hey we have
Missouri nice California Turkey and
Coover okay
yeah in perpetual chess podcasts did a
good preview interview with Daniel King
actually haven't listened to the whole
thing but the the first half was it was
very informative
uh yeah South Korea it's got to be a
more normal time there Cincinnati
nice I was supposed to go to Ohio next
month for the the national high school
championships unfortunately it's not not
going to be taking place 94 in blocks
trying to do something I could play a
four I'll play a four
[Music]
yeah sometimes like when you're when
you're in control you want to be patient
you want to just play restrictively
I mean there's so many things to do in
this position but yeah I very soon like
94 to f6 and I want to open up lines on
the Kings side like once g4 can be
played then either the G or H file will
be open and you know what to do for
black
oh also I have a new emotes I've I
wonder if it if I got approved I made it
like an hour ago
let's see hey okay it looks looks to be
present people can find it and use it
maybe no challenges I don't know I'm
playing a tournament now so perhaps
after this tournament I can take
challenges so you have to wait a little
bit hour and 44 minutes go for this long
you know really just going for
eventually means I'm already actually
imagining there's one mating idea if we
if I played out of six and I got a pawn
to f6 and the bishop goes away and the
night goes away they'll have Queen takes
f8 and rook da mates ooh
c5 I didn't see that move coming I
should have sensed the rook aligned with
my queen I mean I could just take the
pawn then rook c6 oh but then I take
another pawn oh but that my bishop Hanes
c5 is a good move
a good fighting move
my Queens tied down to this pawn - I
would like to take but that loses a
piece unless like Bo Ted's Cabot's but
let's hold off Queen e7 yeah let's play
Queenie Sutton will probably end up
trading like I'll lose this pawn I'll
win this pawn it should be okay yeah but
what to do he moves I felt like it
needed its own emotes
I'll probably end up replacing the the
wind emotes soon as the Chicago winds
got knocked out another day McQueen
seasick so black doesn't take the pawn
it allows 9:06
black wants to play see for calculating
this Bishop takes pawn takes e4 I've
worked he six to maybe I'll start with
rook t6 yeah no need to calculate
oh it's funny I don't like the caro-kann
I don't dislike the Carroll Colin but
yeah I'm not a fan not a fan of it the
same way I'm a fan of some of their
openings but I understand that it does
have some resemblance to London
you got similar structures that's a
completely respectable opening at higher
levels it's not a bad opening to play
for a windows black okay let's take and
take your I've gotten kind of given up
on the attack on the kingside just
trying to win material and simplify
let's play this Krishna welcome back
okay it's five four over this plot hangs
it gets weird like takes never mind
think I'll just take and we're gonna
work to D one Oh use channel points to
suggest openings is that where
could use channel points for like a
highlight message yeah I'll look into
like customizing the channel points
could be interesting but yeah I'm open
to taking opening suggestions but the
best time so to suggest is like right
after game finishes and the new name is
starting this Bishop is kind of stuck
this Bishop is also kind of stuck let's
start with Bishop c4 wanna play b3
ah your uni is on two weeks break your
board I'm sure
yeah I can only imagine how all of you
have been affected yeah how many people
in the chat are like students and are
now all of a sudden break because I know
at least in the u.s. a lot of schools
have shut down at least a lot of
University is I assume just schools in
general yeah I mean in terms of advice I
can give like try and be productive
especially if you're not given like
assignments or coursework be proactive
like learning learning things on your
own online I take advantage of the
Internet I can recommend like trying to
just start projects or do like find some
online course websites a lot of
universities I believe offer like
subscriptions to some online course
sites I just blundered this thing or
just get really good at chess
also watch the candidates candidate
starts in a few days I think it's uh
it's got to be one of like the biggest
sporting events in the world that hasn't
been canceled I should have taken the
night oh oh I forgot about this move I
got so distracted I'm so thankful the
bishop didn't the rook otherwise yeah
that could have been disastrous okay my
Kings gonna walk in you got really
careless sir
where's my mates this is a weird mating
pattern but it works ok good game
attack of the love yeah I haven't played
the white side of a dragon in a while
I'll quickly check the theory oh gee for
more puck yeah maybe g4 makes even more
sense to discourage H 5 H 5 for black
masters database
Oh d5 here interesting move scores well
for luck
so g4 with g4 if d5 of g5 would be good
for whites
[Music]
okay it's hard to look back and forth
the game and the chats I'll try my best
let's go back to the tournaments this is
a time I'm happy to take opening
recommendations oh it's two weeks enough
to get really good at chess it's enough
time to like improve different areas of
your play you're not gonna like become a
GM and a few weeks but yeah I mean you
can devote time to working through
whether it be a book or online course or
just play play more serious training
games or work on like an opening report
or all these openings London please I'm
black okay Black Lion it's being
suggested I don't see any like a black
Kings Indian yeah I was looking for for
something that would work against Knight
f3 so I'll play basically a King's
Indian set up why it's probably doing
the same thing so he might have okay
we'll have slightly asymmetrical
position so this is a King's Indian
seventh it's solid sometimes offers some
attacking chances later on
[Music]
I'm gonna play Bishop g4 just space
something stinks now I'm wondering if I
can just take and then take on e4 it's
very common in King's Indian like
there's x-ray vision tactics
so yeah the ideas takes takes takes if I
take so I need four I just take and I'm
gonna pawn so takes takes takes white
takes here I take here so both queens
are hanging white takes here I take here
I'm be Savin is hanging in the end but
so is b2 so there's a knight takes b7
Knight takes B - I'm just scared about
Bishop takes B - Bishop takes B to rook
v1 and when my bishop moves then the
light moves and my rook strapped this b8
would be controlled but then things
Bishop f5 hitting the rook and Bishop
takes Bishop takes B 1 and then rook
takes B 1 or we know the bishop the
bishop would have moves so rook takes me
one takes look up a pawn yeah let's do
it
it was a weird line I'm just banking on
Bishop f5 working we'll see what happens
okay yeah hopefully I'm not blundering
but curious of my opponent just like
watch all of that it sees my blind spot
I can also take here which is
interesting as well because there's a
bishop t5 possibilities Thank You Warren
William appreciate the message yeah I
guess this time of day it's insomnia for
some people and just middle of the day
for for other people oh I forgot Knight
takes T six as possible so I'm probably
not gonna be on material or maybe I will
because after takes Knight takes g6 I've
rook b8 lights hanging if takes takes c4
still hanging on threatening to do stuff
to the rook for example c5 Knight c4
trap zero
okay
oh I forgot did I forget something
maybe I didn't so yeah Rock v8 I mean I
could also I could consider taking and
then Bishop takes a AIDS well the
problem is Bishop g2 it doesn't work
okay let's play rock b8 it's a messy
position I'm actually curious like how
many games have gone down this weird
line cause I feel like this is this is
probably a sequence that has occurred
before yes so here I was thinking I can
just take and the rook straps and the
Knights still old 97 check though okay
so I could take here yeah I think the
problem with taking is 97 King h8 and
then the bishop the bishop will move
let's say Bishop f4 and when I take take
ya White has two pieces
I'm realizing this is gonna be pretty
draw like takes takes it's just officer
Clark bishops a pretty symmetrical
structure oh yeah let's take hell this
thanks for subbing that's a new name the
middle of the day insomnia what is that
huh okay I wanted to take care it
doesn't work though I mean Bishop d4 so
this is all the one targets this Bishop
can't defend I have the same target but
yeah box definitely slightly better here
hey this move and bishop d5 might be
possible
yeah let's start with this you're gonna
try and win this somehow it's not gonna
be easy
yeah so I'll have to move the bishop I
could play c5 but it looks too
symmetrical
Oh c5 White's a little bit tied down
I guess I can also do this it's very
similar but if I do this there's Bishop
takes f7 I have to play c5 yeah if I
move my Bishop anywhere there's this
okay yeah there's still pressure a crook
b1 always runs into Bishop takes f2 and
then it's nice said after rook takes f2
I take this check so I has no time to oh
so I can get this right
check King g2 is gonna be a slightly
annoying oh actually oh okay Kim G -
would have been very strong and probably
would have just equalized
because I would have had to take move my
bishop and then there would have been
this attacking both pawns in this line I
have work B AIDS
[Music]
now yeah I'm up I think I'm just up a
clean pot of course I want to move my
king away and I've untangled maybe f5
well
bicycle gifting subs thanks so much and
bicycle aces up appreciate that
gifting subs to Emma's alive I say that
right
I'm Misha alive kappa lack of capital oh
it sounds like a male of fraternity
Brian 29 piano or 2090 and $21.99 piano
let's play King g7 we have dirty Dan
official and little Shep what's a Shep
is that like a sheep but little okay
let's play yeah let's play check and
then f6 and then this yeah thanks again
bicycle in two more subs if Sultan
central subbing for two months
hello we have lonely pod subbing for 11
months
hi ok so let's play off six this seems
very close to winning because Bishop e5
is coming the pawns gonna be weak
that's a made threat
White has what has this defense or this
defense
Wow okay so there's this is there going
to be g5 mate there might be it's very
close to g5 mates
okay age six thing is why can play g5
and it's not quite mate
[Music]
I'm searching
each shoes hanging I mean here g5 takes
King g4 it's very close
well then Bishop takes h2 and rook g3 is
very hard to stop like something a bit
more convincing name Bishop f4 there's
about four rookie seventeen age
sixty-five takes here and then mates
meanwhile I'm turning Bishop g5 means I
[Music]
should have played g5 earlier oh he
should've played yeah yeah g5 earlier or
the maybe slowdown f6 yeah so what's
amazing attack in the endgame that's not
too common
Oh Pete's to peak I was trying to follow
this context yeah I designed my logo
actually design my logo back when I was
an FM and then it was very easy to
change the f2 and I thanks for the game
toko yeah I think meters is unstoppable
I would have liked to get some g5 mates
but that's okay back to tournaments oh
we have a we have a berserker but
there's lots of time to catch up
yeah back back in college I was a lot
more a lot more involved with graphic
design I honestly thought I would not be
doing chess like so much after
graduation I thought it would be doing
like more freelance work more web design
visual media but it kind of meshed
together nicely
I think out of like although all of the
logos I've made they've all been like
chess related made the logo for the the
Chess Club and scholastic center of
Atlanta so the first one I made was a
University of Illinois chess team okay
g3 who the Hungarian my previous stream
I I played h5h for and it was fun but
this time I think I'll just control the
center
I'll see what weight is up to be three
okay double fiend keto white might be
going for a hippo and the best way to
hunt the hippo is pushing pushing the
rock on just trying to do some weakness
[Music]
what did I study my first major was math
and computer science but then eventually
I switched to interactive digital media
which I enjoyed a lot more I played this
as if night here I have g5 trafficking
the night otherwise I might have to move
back I'll play h4 I wanna play h3 to
make white undeveloped the bishop it's
so much fun
[Music]
okay h3
so why it's white move both of these
pieces twice but how - okay so the
question is how to maximize advantage
this bishop before it looks interesting
and not if six looks normal
Bishop before budget before if take size
D for a three takes that's good
so here I guess a three immediately
there's a funny line takes takes d4
bishop moves back III takes takes but
then there's not f3
so here here it takes takes and maybe
just not f6 ser because then if takes I
have d4 Bishop here it takes still not a
3mm
okay this isn't exactly what I want to
do but I'm gonna allow the Queen trade
if takes takes so put the position is
just really good just a matter of
developing further yeah I dunno HTML and
CSS it's been a while since I've I've
written in those languages but I did
take a few courses in terms of web
development I found done a lot more work
on WordPress for making functional
websites hmm what's the significance
also white noise welcome back
Oh for 13 months ah yeah very recently
it was it was Friday at the 13th
I should have seen this coming
it's so excited to play this but how to
make this work there's takes takes d4
bishop moves back
I mean I'm maybe just this and before
ooh
so if before there's possibility of
taking oh that's so nice I think is it I
don't know wait to see what my opponent
does ah yeah before this would have been
such a nice tactic I could still take
over then III I take c3 the bishop gets
trapped
except maybe it doesn't because my here
and then the pawn is hard to defend I
guess I can do this
turning III to chat the queen bee so
nice
yeah just to show like in this position
never mind I'll show after the game I
start let's move whoa it's a thousand
bits
no it's twenty five on your bits thanks
white noise thanks so much
I was generous okay the bad things are
about tapped into whites because yeah
the Knights attacked but more
importantly and threatened to win the
Queen channel my inner yasser ID
oh yeah the upon half - it's very much a
Yasir move
[Music]
yeah sorry if I missed comments in the
chat oh how do you pronounce feed a yeah
feed a at least that's how I say it
oh if I play this and takes takes takes
takes I mean it wins a rook or no it
wins exchange maybe a six first it's
also this move so many moves now let's
just play this a simple
well it's gonna be able to develop but
I'll be up material hey we have Germany
welcome to the the Germans not sure
whether to give up this pawn I get the
rook to the file
mmm gonna be greedy holding on to my
pawns yeah so I'm trying to take this
pawn and eventually trap the rook also
some idea of this kick the knight
[Music]
so I'll start with this if I were to
take first service Bishop takes g7
trying to provoke the night block the
Bishop e5 what is this
Lutz it's take I don't play g6 what what
does this pawn structure look at this
this is just a brand new pop that's a
brand new pawn structure just pawns I've
two pawns on the third rank White has
one pawn in six Frank there's other
threat I guess what kind of wants to
take the bishop play King King can move
up the thing is these pawns restrict
both of these pieces those pawns
defended thankfully in this pawn it's
hard for for white to attack there's
never a bishop d4 and controlling d4 I'm
controlling all these squares
so I don't really see what white does
here king b1 ah wants to play this move
so let's just defend but how maybe it's
not so simple
maybe this move or this move ooh
okay so I'll play this move or this move
can start with this move but hangs upon
[Music]
trying to figure out how to do this I
mean I'm up enough material but I want
to be accurate let's play this first
yeah I'm gonna lose this pawn but I'll
probably win this and maybe this
assuming like goes for this plan yeah I
wanted to play this move but there's
Richie one and this pawn would be
hanging ooh my bishop stays alive I have
this move there's Mike c5 maybe I'll
start with this
[Music]
oh I just forgot the Knights hanging
I forgot rooks moves sideways I play
that way too quickly
those mutual blindness not even wearing
my blindfold
I mean thankfully it's it's not like
resolved changing I just assumed I
trusted my opponents like this triple
attack okay but I'll still have fun
start with Bishop d5 I'll play d6 nest
[Music]
yeah that was a wake-up call
yeah geforce coming
g4 is not something I should allow but
I'm gonna have to
yeaji for rockets for hmm
probably have to move back
I won't play g5g for and the structure
this pawn structures are really just
confusing play g5 like look at these
pawns all these pawns are separated
I just lost upon I just got confused
with all the pawns being on weird
squares and 4g8 I'm still up the
exchange - so no reason to panic
yeah I don't flag I still have time
White's go home in this pawn though mmm
though maybe not because if the rook
tries to win Wow
Ritchie - I assume that was a mouse slip
but it was also a nice gift
yeah whites back to being stuck that was
Ralph Brooke g3 it would have been more
of a fights but I was gonna say in this
position if the brook tries to win the
pawn never mind
I'd have to focus still as a d5 this is
very hard to stop there's no way to stop
at the bishops tuck I was gonna say if
if this and I win this pawn if this this
I win this pawn so it kind of makes up
for me missing this move
yeah then just free nights yeah okay
waking up ninth place I've not deserts
yet
oh there's yeah there's just over an
hour left if I play someone below mm
maybe I'll bezerk but I'll take opening
recommendations tell me what to play I
have 19 seconds what opening for a white
efore d4g for London London London okay
play London my favorite opening the
first two suggestions were London and
then next white game will play e4 the
Slav 797 hmm
I know what box is gonna play this setup
sort with 92 if this I'll play this I
forgot to berserk so focused on opening
recommendations expecting g6 Queen b6
interesting here I'll play c4 and
gambling the pawn Oh beserk basically
cuts my time in half so I would start
with 5 minutes I'll first draw
no thanks
you rook b1 I wanted to take but them
Knight takes is kind of annoying
that's probably the wrong approach but
I'm going for it it still takes takes
but then Bishop c4 yeah some night take
side Bishop c4 so I gamma the two pawns
25 good move
Oh
93 is a trance I probably have to take
it's not exactly all I want now IV 4 no
that's still interesting hey Queenie six
that's a good sign
[Music]
it's very close to a queen trap like
Knight g5 has to play Queen f6 and then
maybe just like g3 start with this
[Music]
I'm getting another pond
I forgot I have a pawn hanging d4 was
hanging but maybe there would have been
some comp so I'll play e5 there should
be five to take sticks 35
I have to play this
yeah locks locks managing to survive
here
I'm hoping I'll get something at some
points
Queenie six okay ooh
Queenie six allows for like 96 why not
this is a nice example of x-ray vision Z
files about to open a King f8 probably
best move and now I can win can win one
pawn back
it seems weird to take the bishop but I
think it made sense cuz light Spurs are
very weak and I went upon
that's a weird game so far
but I'm trying to keep up some attack
defy the move d5 is almost trapping a
queen Queen has the square in the square
should note that point is also tied down
to the night hmm there is a smooth
there's a smooth
just keep pushing pawns this is nice
because why I can't play you six
allowing this meanwhile I just want to
take it takes here I take with Queen
okay the Knights just hanging so let's
take it if Queen takes I have the
intermediate check and I'll be out to
pieces it was nice
that's kind of a weird game I mean well
I could have taken this pawn on d4
there's not too many gambits for there
down just like three pawns
[Music]
I would imagine computer probably
prefers black but there's probably some
conversation - - - okay Queen b3 it'd
still be a fight
oh can you please explain to us how you
included the random challenge picker
someone wrote me a Chrome extension she
I think originally it was get prophet
who wrote a very simple extension and
then the user stock vez added onto it
and allowed for subs to connect their
leech s accounts so I'm very grateful
for people who who know how to to write
code yeah give her off it is here thanks
good profit so yeah for those curious
you can see how like that get profit
just sharing it first okay let's let's
not desert I'll pay you for so I
remember someone requesting a Roy oh but
now we have Sicilian um what do people
like I'll stick with just mainline I
guess or maybe not I'll play Bishop e5
check this has been a slight sideline I
enjoy playing Queen takes e7 Castle Bowl
SG thanks for subbing
yeah my my theoretical knowledge is a
bit hazy in the slide I went through a
period I used to play this like over the
board tournaments but it's been a while
each foreign decks King probably that so
this could be a gambit yeah let's uh
sack upon actually this is coming back
to me if I recall correctly the main
line as takes takes d5 be 594 and then
91 good profit yeah thanks get profit
also things bicycle so many you want
ideas to just push that pawn usually f3
Knight here and then maybe f4 maybe not
and ig5 only move which for
[Music]
I think f4 f4 Bishop III probably was
that was that was Ricky boss Ricky
ninety-nine possible
thanks for the bits welcome also welcome
to everyone else I didn't say hello to
nice to see I still see some new names
here
and returning names this makes sense
debating between this or this but
usually like in a advanced French if
there is a trade you want to develop the
night to see three other son Isaac
ninety-one thanks for solving 93 makes
sense
I'm not sure if I want to play on the
Kings side or the Queen side there's 95
potential
combined with rook p1 there's also pawns
I mean there's f5 ideas
f5 here might just lose upon actually I
5 takes
looks like a cool move like I want to
make it work to get an e6 but it
probably doesn't another sub true/false
with three years instead of ease thanks
for subbing
yeah I'm not entirely sure what to do
I am calculating this I got five takes
takes and then because if ever it takes
live Queen h5 it should be good for
whites saw five takes takes if might
take some bit of d4 because takes takes
48 I probably just keep mine Bishop like
Bishop t4 and I moves in the f6f-5 takes
takes his Bishop takes but that looks
terrible for black so I'll still have
vision d4 and ends and I guess Queen d6
rook or either rook e1 or 22 and there's
too much pressure so what's the main
line here it takes takes Knight takes
Bishop d4 there's Queen g6 here but same
thing we need to I think I will play a
five so I think in Lisa lines that I see
the black is running into some issues
and intuitively this is very thematic
cuz I want to open the center with a
king on castled there's some idea to of
course a v6 or oMG for
yeah apologies for the background noise
it's a fridge the fridge makes noises
and then stops making noises at random
times I would unplug the fridge but I
did a massive shop yesterday not too
massive but a lot of food that I don't
think wants to spoil so soon I went to
Trader Joe's yesterday and all the milk
was sold out so I got at least all the
regular milk was sold out so I got
chocolate milk which is kind of sad it's
been at least a decade since I've bought
chocolate milk did you buy 288 rolls of
toilet paper I don't think they sell
toilet paper at Trader Joe's but I went
to Target they're going well the scheme
is is interesting we're playing through
the whole line that I just calculated
Justin Bishop here
yeah target was completely sold out of
toilet paper it was really spooky okay
so f6 was the final move of my
calculation
you have 6-pound threatening this black
could legally castle
though a flat castles I have f7 rock
here and then I'll win material
I didn't go shopping today or yesterday
it's very early morning right now but
yeah Trader Joe's like half the store
was empty
wow how lock just resigns f6 BAM it's
got some f6 BAM he looks always play-off
six
I think box just in trouble here I was
not expecting resignation but yeah I
guess I'm guessing the best sign it's a
castle and give up exchange rook a fate
first yeah it's not reasonable but maybe
opponent just wanted to move on that
five the best move maybe it's up there
kind of five takes takes castling is a
very hard move to play but only move
that keeps back with maybe some
advantage hmm okay doctor tournaments in
fourth place very tight group at the top
my favorites yeah I assume you're
referring to candidates probably MDL
[Music]
I'll play something solid
oh please berserk I forgot to Missouri
my bad
Benoni uh I guess because I said the no
y'all played the noni I didn't want to
play the noni maybe I won't be able to
play the noni oh my phone's playing a
London ah
so with this line I'm gonna play I
accidentally went into this other day
and there's interesting idea Bishop e6
followed by Queen b6 because then Queen
b3 will be prevented and that's all I
know
but it looks kind of cool I think like
takes in ninety five is another idea
yeah MV Allah and Fabi would be the two
players I'm rooting for the most they
play in the first round actually
remember was it was back in August I
played tennis with them like right after
their draw in the same fuel cup and
remember hearing them discussing the
game I think it was the most recent
classical game they played there Fabiana
was white and I think Fabiano was saying
he went through like 25 moves of opening
preparation and he had prepared like the
whole egg game they thought it still
wasn't enough let's let's take in 95 I
mean jingler n is probably I mean of
course like Dingley Ron and Bobby are
the two clear favorites but
we'll see what happens I honestly
wouldn't be surprised like something
unexpected happens just given that like
there's already been some controversy
with like a job of dropping out and just
a whole kind of dynamic of what's going
on in the world but assuming players can
just focus on playing good chess play
this move yeah speaking of focusing
playing good chess you'll play this move
this shouldn't become too concerning I
didn't really calculate c4 but I assume
at least there's night before and yeah
now there's pressure against both of
these pause
this looks like a sad move but it
prepares B five candidates starts it
actually every round starts at this time
it's currently 6 11 a.m. it will start
at 6 and Central Time
least if you're in the US and they play
I think it starts on Tuesday they play
three rounds and then have a rest day
and it's what is it 14 no yeah 14 rounds
total right it's a double round-robin
age six is a move might be six might
just be winning material whites under
severe pressure here because the Knights
pinned and about to be attacked four
times also the Queen's about to be
attacked and the Queen's also tied down
to the night I can't really I guess I
could move here that would be a weird
move I assume I have some tactic after
Queen b5
I'm probably just taking an a6 like
Queen B five takes takes a six
the Queen has to move back and then b5 o
if Queen a 4 B 5 and if Queen B 3 I've
1985 so here takes takes here Queen B 3
and the 95 everything else I'll just
play 95 and hit the night in Queen
I'm not sure what the protocol is with
fans at the tournaments I would suggest
looking at fides website I know they put
out a few statements I was like beep on
hanging no because a bishop would be
hanging material well thank you
when you say play odd games odd has a
few meanings because odd can mean can
mean weird a lot of my games can be
weird
I assume you mean like material odds oh
my phone's going into this let's just
verify take stick say six yeah so Queen
takes here the digit aints also there
might be naive five with like some queen
chopped takes takes a six why am I
saying takes Knight takes e4 Bishop
takes e4 a six yeah that looks good
well I can get like maybe two pawns for
the piece but this should be good enough
yeah Lee chess actually does allow
material challenges but to do it like
the person who wants to play me has to
set the material odds and to do it you
you have to challenge from position and
you just choose whatever position you
want to start from stick yeah okay so
let's play six making me hungry I don't
have any steak
I've roast beef to make a sandwich
okay so yeah I mean this is obvious but
this might be even even prettier no I'll
just take your first attack the rook
it's very close to a queen trap I mean
it refract here of the Queen has to move
force in p6 thinking Bishop b5 oh but
the pawns hanging
so maybe f6 first
what are the odds my opponent resigns
that would be two games that wrote f6
resigns he likes just out of peace
no more counter play against this and
then if if the bishop moves anywhere I'd
imagining just Bishop b5 and then rook
b8 is hard to stop Bishop f4 ooh
counter-attack okay Bishop e5 is one I
wanted to play anyway because of c4 or
a4 I have this make of bigger threats
[Music]
yeah it's 6:17 a.m. I know it's
different times in different parts of
the world yeah maybe I can do a tutorial
on how to like give odds challenges and
maybe like after this tournament ends
perhaps all encourage it
okay point resigns that wasn't my scheme
nice way to like take down the London
Sun especially if you're a benoni player
I would recommend this set up this nice
nice way to exert pressure and you
basically use wastes weaknesses so I use
the B to pawn the bishop on that for so
it sees initially and then eventually
the Queen on C to pawn on d4 this was a
threat and white yeah white got into
trouble with Queen b3 okay second place
I should probably start buzzer King it's
not desert to single game
you all probably stick around for a
little bit after this treatment Oh
bicycle off to bed
we have PT I don't know what that stands
for but yeah get some rest
you forgot to pay contractors army
forgot to pay contractors oh man
well yeah good luck with everything
stay stay safe stay strong thanks for
stopping by
let's play oh let's buzzer what is this
once reading Lazarillo lady 5.97 I saw a
Fabiana play this may be in protest
again who's that
Oh art Beasley welcome back thanks for
joining
good morning it's something for nine
months
yeah I'm on Central Time so I think
sunrise is just about to take place
see for a while
let's take opt is physical training ha
[Music]
fate Weaver UK thanks for subbing ooh I
just miss that no I didn't do this move
for a moment I thought I was losing a
[ __ ] but I might be winning a pawn or
maybe not Queen d2 yeah we're gonna
trade so I want to play e5 then 95 I
should probably start with a 6 it looks
like a slow move but my p5 would be
really annoying I can dry rose okay so
e5 this Bishop is actually quite strong
why it's probably slightly better here
but if I can develop my LightSquared
Bishop hopefully it won't be too bad
[Music]
I'll develop the Kings side first
another saw bicycle gifting a sub 2 I
spark monkey every night thanks for
thanks for subbing
oh let's play like c5 maybe trying to
initiate some trade okay I know this
looks really slow but this Bishop has a
hard time developing because I'm
controlling these squares Bishop g5
would have been annoying
okay a3 considering sac in the pond but
I should probably play rugby AIDS
yes I over defend the pot the goal is to
develop the bishop if before I might
consider Bishop D for provoked this
should be to my King might stay in the
center it's gonna take a lot of effort
to win this position thanks for the
reminder
welcome back Lysa Mary uh D 1 in 3
minutes it's still enough time to uh to
rely on I'm not sure if this is a great
move it is an open file but I have ideas
of Bishop III now okay that move make
sense go take my take with the bishop
it seems weird to give away the bishop
hair but I am trying to imbalance things
there's actually an eye strap in this
position which hoping light walks into I
should know and may be threatening this
move
yeah we're already approaching an
endgame but yeah I'm gonna have to rely
a lot more on intuition in terms of
evaluation white does have the bishop
hair but I think I have a better king
the king is more useful in the center
that's a fine move challenge the file
the Trop was if white plays before then
this wins material because I cut off
defense and attack the rope if I win
this or this exploit the pawn but III
happens
I lost bishop before yeah White's
untangling I guess we'll go for this
there should be four kini Yeats yeah my
king actually might be a target in the
center ideally I'd like to play King e6
but then Bishop h3 I'm still attacking
the pawn
[Music]
have a very kind of strategic and Gail I
play this to Reviver of d6 some lines
like I wanted to play d5 but work t6
would be slightly painful play b6 I
think the ideal setup is a 5 Roxy in 97
and everything's defended I start with
this I love this takes takes over work a
foreign end
efore might come but then maybe mind i
can migrate to d4 you have the goal is
to exploit these pawns it's mine D in 96
as well struggling with airless today
[Music]
promise b6 is weak let's start this
I mean it can be patience but not to
patience to move quickly
pawns attacks 5695
it's gonna be hard to win the tournament
first place is running away with it
[Music]
why has a tactical trick it's probably
okay why does have this move my king is
kind of over words that was a bit
unexpected and take Oh but Bishop c6 Wow
the rookie too
yeah okay - saves me I should be up upon
and still that move though yeah it takes
takes
[Music]
that was very risky I got a lot c5 there
[Music]
better
one's going to try and flag me
[Music]
so I defend the H pawn and I went to c7
pawn
I should pretty be a pretty
straightforward win plenty of time
[Music]
ooh
[Music]
let's not pre-move that almost prema
queen bee - there and it still would be
winning but don't want to sack a queen
[Music]
I'll remove this
I know it's complicated
White has two two legal moves I can't
claim victory because my time is so low
undo this sort of meeting idea okay Rosa
it was a tense hang game Wow I was a
very tense in me Oh first place lost so
there is still some hope I do have time
for two more games I think I mean that
game went pretty much the full distance
Thank You Ricky yeah trying to stay
clean so first place is still playing
waiting for my next my next opponent I'm
not gonna take opening recommendations
but I'll play I'll play aggressively
never played this opponent before I mean
I'm sure I'll play an opening that
someone will support me playing the
opponent gonna move has three seconds
Oh opponent moves okay yes was just
killing time
play of six yeah we're gonna have a
Italian or a Vienna depends what white
plays here I am adjusting my sleep
schedule for candidates
oh my puns
in chat really Oh Alden how's it going
I'm okay when people watch and play
don't think it affects things too much
yeah the idea I mean happy to share my
ideas especially 76 castling a for if
we're is actually a trendy move these
two he's an Italian to gain space I'm
not sure if it's usually played so early
but it doesn't move
oh the three was actually a heart symbol
yeah thanks for subbing for four months
welcome back yeah that's the move let's
play this move again I'm just trying to
be aggressive allowing this capture I
probably take with rook the rook gets
misplaced a little bit but that's life
Bishop g5 Bishop g5 walks into this move
and this was a yeah this is a dream now
still takes a little bit of work I'm
trying to calculate like how to maximize
advantage
because 92 is gonna be a idea for whites
[Music]
Wow yeah so Whiteside used to take and
then takes and then takes I'm gonna be
out material in the end get up a lot of
material here yeah tough game generally
I recommend if you're playing Italian I
recommend c3 that stops all these my D
for shenanigans and it helps you prepare
d4 or even be for later be for a for its
what what a lot of like talk GM's are
doing these days and then you should do
this man tonight maneuver and then later
Bishop III okay thanks for the game ooh
okay so there's there's definitely hope
here to catch up first place just
started a new game yeah I'm gonna
continue buzzer King
oh must eq subbing for a year thanks so
much musky q appreciate that yes
sometimes i overlooked like the length
of time of subs yeah it's nice to see
like a lot of the people are hitting the
one-year mark are you gonna host some
live commentary on the candidates games
no I'll be working for st. Luke's chess
club more behind the scenes doing daily
recaps of kanjyani and and handling
their social media
I should c4 is now the great move it
makes d4 stronger
I might make a guest appearance so on
the the live show yet to be determined
I might be helping with like like
content for the live show this is a nice
I'm a classic trap black had to take
care after d5 but yeah the commentators
in st. Louis will be Yasser Maurice and
Alejandro Ramirez will you post your own
analysis vids of the Canada Games that's
something I wanted to but I'm gonna have
to take it day by day and see how BIG's
like the workload is also depends if
there is like
there's worthy games to analyze I could
take here
I guess with candidates all the games
should be worthy but I'm hoping there's
at least like a decisive game every
round though there's probably gonna be a
good chunk of rounds where all the games
or draws aunty was welcome back Sharky
croc also welcome back yeah so the Queen
the Queen prevents Spock from castling
it takes takes i I just simplify and
take cure
oh there's some funny line if you're
here here here oh wait a minute
how does that work oh maybe here here
here here here in the castle and the
castle Fork that would be cool start
with this move and pass spawns must be
pushed
yeah it's just a matter of simplifying
take the mites
yeah I should probably just castle here
I'm gonna lose this pawn like Rick be
it's coming but the Kings gonna just be
a sitting duck and the rooks start gonna
come in trying to figure out like the
mating net if I actually want to check
or maybe start with this move any fours
a move start with a check
another five will be any brutal for life
every time I grab up on people are
calling me Yasser I'll accept that mean
pawns are pawns
if King here I fork oh by starting a
fork as well gets a little bit weird
interesting
let's play this move I'm forking like
all the both rooks are now attacked was
like the double fork Knights
mm I'll stay with her so now night 92 is
no longer afford
please just is such a violent sport yeah
especially when there's Knights doing
for King ooh that's a good move some
counter violence but yeah the checks
should be limited
and maid is coming
so here here here in the mates
okay hey first place let's go and still
still probably have to get one more game
in not sure I'm not sure what the time
situation was there
Zurich let's play London stay with
something solid to wrap things up
actually and maybe I'll play something
aggressive
I've been streaming I've been streaming
a decent amount this week maybe every
other day but not often at this time so
yeah maybe there's there's new people
here if you're new if this is your first
time watching on twitch say hi in the
chat or don't say hi in the chat a shout
out to the lurkers okay so yeah I
started the stream about two hours ago
tournament is wrapping up this is uh
just hourly rapid arena hey we have a
song lucky luke might see six trying to
remember what to do probably this move
there's a lot of different like
resources for whites
there's defensive resources but there's
also attacking resources this is a fun
position to play so yeah to win the
tournament
assuming 2nd place wins and passes me b5
you find let's buy d5 expecting 94 I'll
play f3 and idea is to play h4 h5
it would be incredible if MVL wins the
candidates and then goes on to like
defeat Carlson after almost not having
qualified for the candidates that's
interesting move go plate 92 just trying
to defuse blacks ideas yeah I don't care
about my fish it Bishop is hibernating
it's more about just being able to
expand realizing this is still gonna be
tricky but okay this is type of position
I want keep an eye on this game
yeah so I think it's important that
determined time is not less than my
opponents time so I really should not
use more than the minutes more could
make things difficult
and yeah I'm probably not gonna look too
much at the chat for the remainder of
this game yeah so f5 I was expecting to
take this rook takes her Bishop takes
out of g4 if pawn takes Queen g5 doesn't
quite work I have this move so this move
so the idea is that if King takes I have
g4 takes takes takes rook g1 so that
can't actually take twice and then I'll
get some pawn storm because takes rook
g1 Queen d7 Bishop h3 or Queen g5 soon
leg has to move oh wow really
Oh Queen h4 Wow
does this work I have Queen here Bishop
would be pinned in two directions
there's not a four it's getting
complicated I have to go for this so I'm
attacking the bishop and the pawn I'm
currently down two pawns
the bishop is Leroy Pinter both the king
and the Queen
[Music]
okay there's Queen g5 king b1 also
there's not a four I can probably just
take yeah neither four it takes rook see
it's not possible because I take the
bishop doesn't defend
oh that move move I forgot about
let's take I'm trying to just get to the
king they probably throw in some rook
move to unpin my knight in prepare of g3
mmm interesting it's probably a good
move I don't want to open the C file
three actually let's go for it it's very
risky but I just spent too long there
too it's a complicated position though I
don't know who's white
it looks like yeah looks like I'm gonna
get past some idea is just to keep
taking pawns what let's start by taking
business pinned a Knights attacked twice
Wow
this move
this is so complicated the works not
defended but if here I take and defend
meanwhile Bishop h3 could be a threat so
this works tied down
I mean I'm threatening to take the night
to but rooks lie down to this rook lots
of geometry bishops pinned it looks like
everything's just tied down for luck 23
if I take it's probably a good move
it takes takes
take take like this
I don't think I'm getting needed
I mean the main line is take stakes here
here takes takes takes I win e5 in the
end and then black pushes it takes a
little bit of time to unpin my Knights I
should control each one
[Music]
still not past Oh did did this person
lose okay
so I might be able to win the tournament
without actually finishing the scheme
[Music]
it's a very weird position like there's
so much tension between everything
between the Queens of rooks
like both Kings are unsafe I'm almost
getting naded thankfully takes takes I
defend your rook T ones only move so I'm
gonna lose the bishop I'll win the pawn
oh wait a minute this is probably not a
good pre move cuz I could potentially
take oh wow oh no it doesn't work I
thinking takes I have this move but
Bishop is bishops move backwards sadly
there's also b3 no that's no good so
let's take
and Paul is kind of fast I guess before
makes most sense
eh fry have this move try and slow back
down but this is why I had calculated
earlier is that like the pawns fast but
I get that my deaf - I assume like worst
case scenario I should be able to sack
the night for the pawn yeah for this
game is not going to finish so now it's
just about trying to win this game and
keep a clean score
that's incredible the timing I didn't
calculate like this precise variation
that I'm not even threatening to take
the bishop because black Queens I mean
probably I'm just worse here but I mean
I'm up on time hey I think I won the
tournaments if these standings are
correct let's focus on the game yeah I
really do much I have to play knight
each one
mmm okay I thought black was gonna meet
he go for a draw but now this makes
sense
so I've rook c4g Brooke c4 makes a ton
of sense because now I've ripped g1 I
check in with the pawn I buy myself some
time I just want to start pushing my own
pawns
play this move oh I forgot black had a
threat though I forgot now this is a
threat oops
hi and 9f2
I have two doesn't work so check yeah
I'm probably gonna lose this it's some
trick
and trying to take the pawn doesn't make
any sense not have to ok so there's only
one line which give me any hope just
speaking sure though yeah so the line is
this and then push and then help black
flex because they look stuck
hopefully the pawns are quick the smart
move cake check doesn't work watching a
flag though interesting
yeah tough tough finish in opponent
played really well and then got too low
on time I guess I was a crazy game I was
like a long calculation I should analyze
the game by should also celebrates hey
it's confetti so oh maybe I don't know
what happened I thought this person was
playing a game but maybe you didn't
finish or maybe just one not sure yeah
congrats to second and third the fun
tournament had some interesting games
[Music]
Thank You Ricky 99 ball so thanks for
sticking around and thinks everyone who
stuck around
I appreciate the the viewership after
the first game of this tournament I said
I would maybe put it on YouTube but
maybe I would put the whole tournament
on YouTube so if I do put this on
youtube
thanks for watching future youtube
people you can like and subscribe and
stay tuned for more content